[Music]
so my friend Brian is on his way over
here today he has created a custom piece
of art for the podcast studio so pretty
excited to show you guys this the right
side up or does it matter
it says piece and plants but it's
written rather cryptically and backwards
so you have to look really closely it's
backwards it's all there is to it so
it's easier for me to go backwards and
forwards and some reason when I I start
to write the letters they start to kind
of form a pattern so I just follow the
pattern but I repeat the same word so
that it creates a pattern texture so
when you start you go from around in a
circle and yeah on the outside and yeah
and so it's real so it's I can't work
with lines so it's like I have to like I
have to just run the perimeter and then
run and then kind of circle my way yeah
right
[Music]
it's it's interesting because when I was
young I the only way I could process
what a teacher was saying was to write
it like backwards with my finger on my
leg so that was my way of coping and
then trying to understand it as I got
older it got a little more difficult and
then I started realizing with making a
pattern and so that's kind of how like I
I can't write with lines like I said
earlier so because they they restrict my
letters because I like to like put them
together and then you know who knows why
it all kind of comes together but I mean
I started out in fashion right I studied
textile design it's like I wanted to
find a way to inspire people without
being obvious you know to me like it's a
pattern that looks like that then they
could find out it says or they couldn't
you know I mean it's like it's up to
them but to me it's the message is
inside of it so like the power of water
and then you know and then sort of thing
so I feel like the message is there it's
kind of a blessing to the house is a
blessing to the environment it's never
negative although I've been tempted
mirror writing
some people call it and then there's a
select see it which I am apparently but
it doesn't fell in that they don't
they're writing and dyslexia or separate
parenting so I don't know weird hybrid
yeah again right Wow
yeah that's amazing well thank you well
thank you all right cool
this is the cosmic representation to
honor
Brian's beautiful artistic contribution
of the studio I thought I'd take the
opportunity to give you a little
behind-the-scenes tour of
the studio itself my setup and my
workflow is we get a lot of questions
about that at the outset though I just
want to make very clear this is not a
sponsored video I'm just gonna talk
about the products that I use and I like
so take it at face value we're still
very much in the beginning stages of
trying to figure out how to maximize
this space and I'm not sure this is the
ultimate solution right now there's
still a lot of experimentation that I
would like to do my general rule is keep
it simple the more moving pieces you
have the more opportunity for something
to go wrong so the first piece of
equipment I want to show you is this
this is the zoom h6
and this is what I record all of my
conversations on and this is actually a
step down in complexity from how I used
to do it I used to have a full
soundboard with all the little dials on
it and my friend Jonathan fields who
hosts the good life project turned me on
to this little device and it has changed
the game for me it's basically a
portable recording device with six
inputs it's got four XLR inputs so you
can actually have four different mics
going into it headphones plug right into
here you can use a simple splitter like
this if you want to plug multiple
headphones in so the guest in the host
can listen to the podcast it comes with
a variety of microphone attachments that
you can plug right into the top right
here so even if you can't afford fancy
mics and all this other gear that I'm
gonna walk you through if all you have
is this you can put it on the table in
between two guests attach one of the
external microphone devices it's
fantastic for bringing on the road to
record podcast when I'm traveling second
thing and probably the most important
thing is your microphone
these are shure sm7b they're my favorite
mic they deliver an unbelievable sound
quality they're designed for
professional broadcasting and in studio
voice I think it's fair to say that this
has become the premium mic of choice for
podcasters this was not always the mic
that I used I had to work my way up to
it it's a fairly pricey piece of
equipment coming in at about $400 and
when you're gonna buy - obviously that's
that's a quite an expense I started off
with very low quality mics worked my way
up through a variety of mics settled on
this mic it's my favorite mic it works
fantastically well it's very durable I
take these mics on the road when I
travel they never break they never fail
and they're fantastic things this is
called a cloud lifter it's the cloud
lifter cl1
and basically what it does is it
provides up to 25 decibels of gain to
amplify the mic signal from a dynamic
mic or a ribbon mic which do not have
their own power source they have made a
huge difference in sound quality what
I've noticed is that I can record at a
much lower gain on the zoom h6 and cut
out a lot of the background noise so it
really sounds pristine these mic arms
are made by yellow tech I just really
like them they're super clean and modern
and beautiful you might have seen these
mic stands on the Joe Rogan show that's
the first place that I saw them I just
love the look and the feel and they're
very flexible and on the subject of mic
arms most podcasters do not have a
dedicated studio space or desk to record
their conversations or their show and
for most of you you're just going to
want a basic tabletop mic stand and for
that I suggest these these by or a and
the reason I like these is they have a
foam pad on the bottom which helps to
dampen the sound if there's any banging
or rumbling
headphones there is no end to the amount
of money that you can spend on
headphones and my biggest piece of
advice is that this is not where you
want to invest your money if you have a
limited budget put it into the mics
don't put them into the headphones from
the very beginning from day one I have
always used the sony MDR 75006 their
professional studio and broadcasting
headphones they're incredibly reliable
they're very durable and they're only
like 99 bucks when I'm researching the
guess what I will do is take notes on
one side of the page I'll write down
topic headings that I want to discuss on
the other side of the page I'll
generally write down a number of facts
that I want to remember about the gas I
do a ton of preparation a ton of
research on every guest writing down
notes about the guests from what I'm
reading helps reinforce these ideas in
my memory but then when the podcast
starts I like to shut it put it away
forget it and just be present with the
guests so if you have been listening to
the podcast and you've probably heard a
couple spots that I've done for this new
functional movement furniture company
called fully they're an amazing company
and they sent us a bunch of pieces of
furniture to try out this is called
their Aloha
chair and as you can see it doesn't have
a back and it custom fits to your spine
to create perfect posture and they're
super comfortable they go up and they go
down they adjust height so I've been
using these in the podcast studio for
the last couple months in terms of the
video component of the podcast we have
been shooting with a four camera setup
we have one camera here that's a two
shot we have two cameras on the guest a
medium and a close-up and we have one
camera on me and then Blake and Margo
edit the whole thing together create a
variety of shorter clips that we share
on social media and we're really trying
to find new and better ways of
leveraging
video to get the message out there in
the best way possible the final thing is
whenever I travel whenever I go out of
town I take my podcast gear with me and
I always attempt to record interviews
with interesting people when I'm on the
road I'm going out of town tomorrow so
now I have to pack up all of this gear
some of this equipment is expensive but
the truth is you don't really need any
of it all you really need is a mobile
device with a voice recording app on it
that's all you need you can put it in
between you and another person or just
talking to it yourself cost does not
need to be a barrier to the creative
process the only thing that's really
required is a desire to create and the
work ethic to get it done
[Music]